grouping is used when the data we have
is very large and the groups are called
class intervals in one of our examples
we had seen groups like these 1 2 5 6 to
10 11 to 15 and so on there are a few
things we need to know about class
intervals the class intervals should be
non-overlapping it means that the same
number cannot be present in two or more
groups one number should belong to just
one group all the groups should exhaust
all the data we have with us these three
groups are enough to cover all marks
from 1 to 15 but if we had someone who
scored a 16 these three groups would not
be enough
next the class size or the class width
should be the same class width is the
difference between the two lower limits
or two upper limits of continuous class
intervals so 6 minus 1 should equal 11
minus 6 and 10 minus 5 and 15 minus 10
should also be equal
remember they shouldn't be overlapping
the intervals should cover all values in
the data and the class width has to be
the same throughout there is just one
more condition we need to keep in mind
in the first interval 1 & 5 are class
limits and the average of 1 & 5 is
called the class mark the fourth
condition says that the class limits and
the class marks of each interval should
be integers or simple fractions a simple
fraction is a fraction in which the
numerator and the denominator are both
integers these are the basic rules we
need to keep in mind while making groups
or class intervals